في ايام كاس العالم توقف الحياه العاديه
لدى كثيرين يصبح الحديث الاوحد مباريات
المونديال وايام التي لا تتكرر الا كل
اربع سنوات هذه الايام التي تحمل خصوصيه
هذه المره بالنسبه للمقيمين في منطقه
الخليج العربي لسيما الدول المشاركه في
المونديال حيث يصبح التوفيق بين العمل
ومتابعه المباريات صعبه كل ذلك يدفع
الكثير من الموظفين والعاملين في مختلف
شؤون الحياه الى طلب اجازه او الغياب عن
الحضور الى العمل في سبيل حضور المباريات
هذه الغيابات الموندياليه
العامه حيث تنخفض في هذه الايام بالفعل
الانشغال شبه الكلي الكاس العالم
ومبارياته المثيره
[موسيقى]
طبعا بعد اربع سنوات
[ضحك]
لازم تحضر بس المباريات اللي فيها قدره
يعني
الفريق بيلعب كويس
[موسيقى]
المونديال موجود لكن انتاجيه في خطر هل
بالفعل مباريات كره القدم اثرت على
انتاجيه في العمل حسب البلدان اي بلد اللي
ممكن تتاثر اكثر اكثر شفتي مثلا في
استراليا واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه اقل
الدول تاثرت لانه عبال ما تبدا ساعات
المباريات الساعه 1:00 ظهرا في توقيت قطر
والمملكه تكون انتهت ساعات الدوام عندهم
يعني الدراسه عملت على الموظفين اللي
يعملوا من الساعه 9:00 الى الساعه ال6:00
اتاثروا ب 21 ساعه عمل تقريبا دول الخليج
اللي بتاثر واكثر مننا في اوروبا بعدين
انا على الدول اللي على خط
سينغال وبريطانيا وغيرها اكثر الدول تاثرا
امريكا الشماليه والجنوبيه والجنوبيه اكثر
الدول تماما لانه على بال
فالانتاجه هناك عندهم الكره عباده
كره القدم هذه اول اول خطوه النقطه المهمه
كيف ممكن نستفيد من هذا الموضوع اعجبني
جدا انا كنت في الرياض قبل كم يوم قابلت
مجموعه بريطانيين يشتغلوا في بروجه اكبر
المشاريع الحكوميه عاملين انتم
رائعه يعني التفاعلات الجماعيه عاملين
حاجه اسمها هشام يعني اكثر بين المباراه
يعني شايف
كل المجموعه يجتمعوا وكل طاوله يكونوا
مسؤولين عن مهمه يعطوهم ادوات وانت تسوي
الان الفكره كلها انه هتبني مسار تمشي فيه
الكوره الين نهايه الطاوله فكيف تسير
الكوره بشكل سلس وسليم المراه منها
والفكره منها هذه الجيم انه كلنا نؤثر على
انتاجيه الشركه وتحقيق رؤيتها اذا اي شخص
في اي مكان اكثر سلبا على على انتاجيه
الشركه حيث اثر الانتاجيه الكامله بشركه
في حاجه ثانيه اسمها
صادقات فيها ارقام هذا وقتها يعني لو صارت
بين الاشواق لو صارت بين المباريات لو صار
في المكان نفسه في همم يعني مشروبات انت
صنعت بيئه كثرت حواجز عملت في فريق العمل
زادت الانتاجيه غير الناس اللي ممكن تعتمد
عليهم في الاون لاين يعني علمتنا كيف
نستخدمه ضعيف
ربع الامريكان وثلث البريطانيين يوم واحد
على الاقل بيعمل اون لاين فكيف ممكن
الاشياء
التعبانه تتعامل فيها اون لاين في الاوقات
اللي خارج اعطيك اجازه بعطيك وقتك
تستمتعوا نستمتع مع بعض في مهام معينه
ابغاك تخلصها خلال اليوم انت عاد رتب
جدولك بنفسك